wait
I have no idea what's in here my guess
though is that it's going to be much
cool hats and shirts but it could very
well just be a straight groan so I like
Peter's finger and a ransom note earlier
Rosie why would they just randomly send
us a drone I've been talking to chat
about it oh my God look at all the hat
dude that is it no come on guys no
calling upon my authority as founder and
the same was to give me his gray hat no
I wanted rehab because I'm tired of
wearing black hats all the time
I only have like you know to come back
I'll trade you let your first note or
you got this putting on with us what I'm
going to go Democratic primary
California I'm just going to get a
sandwich a sandwich place the voting in
that thing yeah three three votes for
Trump coming up that's that's exactly
why they get such extremism in their
party you have to be a registered
Republican to vote for a Republican in
the primary so all they do is pan or to
the to the right
I will challenge you to an archery
contest for the hat stoar toughest I do
sir this is going to be a permanent
addition to the store nice I like it I
like it with multiple cups will be black
red gray red maybe one more and then
this will just be posted is a limited
design thanks right oh right you're the
best I wait are those sorts are gonna do
this right now
I mean yes we wear hat and the strip's
count but it only counts if it's right
here right here yeah besides a head
flatter blade nothing no for us no no
one good kills you
all right let's soar touched who's on
remember this
pretty
Oh
very import of it yeah automatic down
here since the woman
conservatively you watch they're here
that's not one more
yeah that's a good deal that's a pretty
clean do it let me pretty fair to little
bow
my hey
oh I see we did